JEFF POSNICK: Hi, everybody.
I'm Jeff Posnick from the
YouTube API Developer
Relations Team, and welcome to
this week's episode of YouTube
Developers Live.
Today's guest is Kris Schroder
from Next Big Sound.
And they're a pretty cool
company that's using--
primarily, we're going to talk
about your Analytics API use.
And really happy to have
you on the show.
KRIS SCHRODER: Great.
Thanks, Jeff.
It's awesome to be here.
JEFF POSNICK: Awesome.
Thank you.
And I want to just go into a
little bit of background on
what Next Big Sound is all about
for the folks who might
not be familiar already.
KRIS SCHRODER: Sure.
So I'm a member of the
Engineering Team, and my role
is focused on integrations
with our
customers and partners.
So that's a little
about myself.
The company itself tracks the
online activity for almost
every band in the world and
then we organize that
information into a centralized
dashboard and provide that
back to the music industry.
So our customers include both
labels, who are very
interested in developing and
marketing artists, as well as
individual bands and band
managers, who are trying to
learn more about their fan base
and promote themselves on
social media and
other networks.
JEFF POSNICK: Cool.
And obviously YouTube is a
huge part of the music
ecosystem--
KRIS SCHRODER: Absolutely.
JEFF POSNICK: --so being able
to get that type of
information for YouTube
play backs I'm
assuming is pretty important.
KRIS SCHRODER: Yeah,
tremendous.
Really interesting in so many
ways too, because it's not
just an amazing way for fans to
connect with artists, but
also you see new acts breaking
on YouTube in new ways that
were impossible before.
So getting a viral video or an
internet meme, or getting
discovered by making covers of
their favorite acts, and
aspiring artists that are trying
to grow a fan base and
get started that way.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
So you mentioned a little bit
about who the intended
audience is.
If you were a smaller act, can
you still use Next Big Sound
or is it mainly for
more established--
KRIS SCHRODER: Yes.
Yes, it's for both.
So all three major record labels
are our customers, but
we also have thousands of what
we call self-serve customers--
individual acts, bands, band
managers, people just getting
started who want to understand
like, I need to take advantage
of all these sources that are
out there, and where am I and
how do I compare to other acts
that I might aspire to.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
Cool.
OK.
Well, that's a bit of a
overview, but it's always
really nice to see live demos
of what we're talking about.
So before we go any further, if
you want to start driving
the web interface.
KRIS SCHRODER: That
sounds great.
JEFF POSNICK: Show us what
you're all about.
KRIS SCHRODER: Cool.
So right now we're looking
at our home page.
We're a web-based
app obviously.
And if I log in, this is the
artist overview home page that
you are taken to.
So any acts like yourself or
others that you're interested
in that you want to report on,
you would subscribe to and
include here.
But what I wanted to show you
was specifically an example of
YouTube data.
So I'm sure we're all familiar
with Psy and his story.
It's amazing.
But if we go in here, we have
a bunch of different data.
This is the artist overview
page, and right now we're
getting a quick look at some key
metrics that I've decided
that are important to me and
really the values for the past
week as well as how they've
changed week over week.
I'm also getting information
on particular tracks on the
left-hand side and then also
gender and age information
from different sources.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
And just to be clear, we are not
here showing any private
data about Psy.
The data on this particular
page is
publicly available data--
KRIS SCHRODER: That's right.
JEFF POSNICK: --about
the YouTube views.
But I know that there is
a separate kind of like
authenticated mode where you're
actually using the
Analytics API to pull some
additional data.
We're not going to be able to
demo that right now, but--
KRIS SCHRODER: So basically--
JEFF POSNICK: --do believe
me that it exists.
KRIS SCHRODER: Great.
Basically, the data that you're
seeing right now is
data that you could go and see
yourself and if you had a
pencil and paper every day,
went and tracked it down.
So it's all public information,
and then for
YouTube Analytics, that
integration--
it's just like you said-- it's
an authorized source and that
gives you much more
granularity.
But just to give you an overview
of the type of
information we have, I think
this will work great.
If we go to the graph section,
I'm looking at a graph of
YouTube views for Psy for
the past 90 days.
And so it's really
interesting.
He has a couple different
spikes.
In addition to collecting data
from multiple sources, social
media, et cetera, we also
collect event data so you can
look at key points in time and
compare them to what might be
driving up that spike in
YouTube plays on that
particular day.
JEFF POSNICK: That's
interesting.
Where do you pull that
sort of information?
KRIS SCHRODER: All
over the place.
So there's different
sources for music--
these names are escaping
me right now--
where you can pull concert
information,
appearances on charts.
If we notice something shows
up-- so like a new video on
YouTube, for instance--
we'll turn that
into an event ourselves.
So really just scouring as
many different possible
sources as we can get
our hands on.
JEFF POSNICK: Cool.
KRIS SCHRODER: Twitter--
JEFF POSNICK: Even for the data
that you might be pulling
from publicly available sources,
it seems like you're
adding a lot of value from
intelligently presenting it
and making some-- you know
helping people discover some
things that they might not see
if they were just looking at
numbers rather--
KRIS SCHRODER: Right.
JEFF POSNICK: So that's
really cool.
KRIS SCHRODER: That's
the goal.
And then another idea--
bringing the YouTube analytics
into Next Big Sound means that
not only can you look at just
the YouTube analytics data but
compare it to the events that
we find and compare it to
other social media sources
and whatnot.
JEFF POSNICK: Cool.
KRIS SCHRODER: Yeah, so
continuing with this example.
So I just looked at events for
this day and it turns out the
reason it spiked there was it
looks like Psy released a new
video, "The Gangnam Shake,"
on YouTube.
So I think we can imagine
what that is.
JEFF POSNICK: Yes.
I don't think we can play
it right now, but--
KRIS SCHRODER: And then
this huge jump, I
mean 48 million views.
This is the release of his
newer video for that
"Gentleman" song, which people
are wondering can Psy do it
again and have another
great hit.
And it looks like at least for
now that's what's happening.
JEFF POSNICK: Cool.
That seems really compelling
unless there's anything else
you wanted to demo.
KRIS SCHRODER: Yeah, I just
wanted to give an
example of if we--
and on top that, like Wikipedia
page views.
Now it's not on the same scale
yet, but if I just change over
to a relative view of the data,
you can start seeing
things like, all right, well
not only did releasing that
video drive people to YouTube
to watch the video, but it
meant people were going online
and going to Wikipedia and
learning about Psy.
And so Wikipedia is an
interesting source,
complementary source, because
that's where people go to
learn about artists
more so than the
artist's own web page.
JEFF POSNICK: Very cool.
Awesome.
Do you want to dive into some of
the technical details about
how you've implemented to this,
and specifically how
you're using the YouTube
APIs to pull--
KRIS SCHRODER: OK.
JEFF POSNICK: So some background
on how you've
actually built this if you
want to get into it.
KRIS SCHRODER: The platform?
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah, what kind
of stack are you running on?
KRIS SCHRODER: Yeah, sure.
Sure.
Definitely.
So the front end is mainly PHP
backbone.js, and then our back
end is mainly a large
Cassandra cluster.
And so that's housing
all of our raw
data, time series data.
It was the perfect database
for that because it's just
great for scaling and handling
that large amount of data,
lots of concurrent rights,
that type of stuff.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
Very cool.
And obviously YouTube Analytics
is one of the major
sources of data for people
who have gone through the
authorization flow and said
explicitly, yes, run analytics
for my channel, so how are you
integrating with that?
What language are you--
KRIS SCHRODER: So that's--
our data integrations,
[INAUDIBLE]
our data collectors and our
data crawlers, they're all
written in Java.
So it's pretty much standalone
Java app
that runs on a schedule.
And then we're using very basic
straightforward standard
HTTP client to go ahead and
create the calls to grab the
data from YouTube, and since
it's JSON, it's really
easy to work with.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
And you go through the standard
OAuth 2 flow in
advance and ask for
credentials and
that sort of thing.
KRIS SCHRODER: Exactly.
So we use OAuth 2 and we have
to redirect the user to a
Google authentication page and
we save that token and then
each day as we go in, we have
to go and refresh those
tokens, so there's a little
bit of management of the
connection of those types of
things that can come up, but
that's the nature of an API,
so no surprise there.
It's actually been pretty
smooth integration.
JEFF POSNICK: Very cool.
So you're kind of running your
analytics polls more or less
on a regular timer.
It's not like On Demand
when somebody
loads a page that you--
KRIS SCHRODER: That's right.
Yeah.
Cause as you can see in our
interface, people are choosing
different time ranges.
So what we actually do is we're
going to go in and we're
going to get the daily values
for every artist that is
registered for every channel
and for every video, all of
the different view metrics,
engagement metrics.
We don't really go into
annotations or some of the
things that are more I feel
like ad focused features.
But plays, unique plays, the
geographic data and the
demographic data, we all
grab from there.
And yeah.
JEFF POSNICK: I don't know if
you've had any outstanding
feature requests for this but
one of the things we did
recently add to the Analytics
API was access to monetization
details, so if you do have
people that have been
clamoring to see how much their
ad revenue has been for
certain videos, you
can now start
exposing that if you wanted.
KRIS SCHRODER: Cool.
JEFF POSNICK: Just throwing
that out there.
Kind of a plug for some new
functionality that we've added
to the API.
I know a lot of analytics users
were asking for that.
KRIS SCHRODER: Cool.
I mean, there's been a lot of
excitement from the industry
about this and from our
record label partners.
I'll have to look into how
this can come into play.
JEFF POSNICK: Very cool.
Any kind of best practices or
anything that kind of you ran
into that was not immediately
clear that you want to share a
solution to or put me on
the spot and ask why we
implemented something
in a certain way?
I'll obviously deflect,
but you know.
KRIS SCHRODER: Yeah, I mean in
terms of the challenges that
we ran into-- just the fact that
we are collecting so much
data on a daily granularity, we
had to be mindful of how we
created our queries.
So as you use the API, you learn
things like geography
and daily having data sliced
by both at the same
time isn't an option.
Right.
And certain metrics can't be
queried with other metrics, so
to get all of that--
JEFF POSNICK: That's another
thing that's actually gotten
better for folks who are
watching who might have run
into this before.
We need to make more noise
about these changes.
But you can now query for
minutes watched, like all the
watch time data, along with the
standard views and likes
and all that other data.
So you did use to have to
do two separate queries.
You can now do them in one.
Maybe that cuts the number
of queries you
have to do in half.
KRIS SCHRODER: That's
going to help a lot.
Absolutely.
JEFF POSNICK: Well it's a good
thing you were on the show.
Yeah, this obviously doesn't
scale super well where we
invite people on the show in
order for them to learn about
new API features, so follow
us on +YouTube [INAUDIBLE]
on Google Plus and we'll make
sure to share these updates.
And we actually do have RSS
feeds now of our documentation
whenever we release something
new, so you can subscribe to
that and find out what's been
added to our different APIs.
KRIS SCHRODER: Great.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah, so a
little plug for that.
OK.
So managing your request time,
and I know that a lot of
partners who've started working
with the Analytics API
have run into that and I think
the temptation's always I want
to request information about
every single video I know
about as frequently
as possible.
I want to get as much data as
possible, and we sympathize
with that, but you do need to
be a little less aggressive
than pulling everything.
Some of the things that we
recommend folks do is for
instance, instead of if you
happen to manage tens of
thousands, hundreds of thousands
of videos that you
want to pull reports for, don't
do it every night but
maybe do it every three nights
and request data for the past
three days.
Something like that.
So you kind of lose a little bit
of the real time element,
but it scales a lot
better basically.
So I'm not sure if that's
something that you kind of--
KRIS SCHRODER: It is.
It is.
The second an artist-- or excuse
me, the second a user
connects their YouTube Analytics
to our dashboard
they're like, great.
Show me all my data.
It's like, all right, well we
have to grab a little bit of
it at a time, maybe five day
segments and work backwards in
time to get all that
data so it'll grow.
But--
JEFF POSNICK: I think you can
do a pretty large date range
in your requests.
KRIS SCHRODER: Sometimes.
Some requests we can, and then
other requests where we want
the geographic data also, each
request is technically its own
single day range, so it ends up
being an extra query just
to get that one day.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
KRIS SCHRODER: So it's
tricky for us.
JEFF POSNICK: We'll see what we
can do about that, because
I'm not really sure why we have
that limitation but maybe
we could help.
KRIS SCHRODER: Besides that, I
mean the big takeaway that I
would say for the API is
that it is extremely
straightforward and flexible.
There's a lot of great
data in there.
Almost everything I've seen
in the YouTube Analytics
dashboard itself is available
through this API, which is
just really awesome.
That's really great.
And then the types of challenges
I ran into I would
say are not deal breakers or
major compared to just the
value that you get
from the API.
Generally, things just work
like they should and--
JEFF POSNICK: That's
excellent feedback.
Hopefully our engineers who
wrote the API are watching and
virtual pat on your
back for that.
And it's great to see these APIs
used in really compelling
and interesting ways.
KRIS SCHRODER: And for me, the
biggest help was the API
Explorer was a great tool to
use and it just really just
clears up any mystery about
what's happening when you make
these queries.
It's pretty straightforward.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah, we've
covered that in some
previous GDL shows.
I'm not sure that we have time
to pull it up now but just
basically you can search for
Google APIs Explorer and it
give you that live interface
where you can try out any
sample queries.
It's not just for the Analytics
API but for all our
data APIs and pretty much all
our Google APIs across the
board without having
to write code.
Specifically, I do this
all the time too.
If you're running an analytics
report, the tricky part is
getting the report
definition right.
It's not necessarily writing
Java code or
PHP code to do it.
It's like, what should
my report look like?
So API Explorer definitely
helps with that.
KRIS SCHRODER: Cool.
JEFF POSNICK: Any other feedback
about the experience
that you want to share?
I know that--
I don't want to take
away too much.
I'm deliberately not asking Kris
certain things cause Kris
is actually going to be onstage
next week at the
Google I/O conference.
He's going to be presenting
somewhat similar material but
some new stuff too about how
Next Big Sound is using
Analytics API as part of
one of our sessions.
So I know not everybody's going
to be able to make it
out to Google I/O. We're going
to have a recording of his
session video available
hopefully not too late after
that, so if you like what you
learned on this show, I
definitely recommend that folks
check out the video once
that's available, once I/O
actually happens, once
[INAUDIBLE], Kris will be
talking in even more detail.
KRIS SCHRODER: Yeah.
We have a lot of great stuff
lined up for that.
Some really good specific
examples of real world artists
where the data has been prepared
and scrubbed, because
it is private data so we--
it's really interesting, but
we have to be careful about
how we show it.
So you'll have to go watch the
Google I/O session to see it.
JEFF POSNICK: Absolutely.
Well great.
So yeah, we are going to be at
Google I/O next week so there
won't be a show at our regularly
scheduled slot but
there's going to be all this
great recorded Google I/O
content that we're going to make
available for folks to
watch after the fact.
And I know that the whole Google
Developers Live series
is going to be live at I/O for
a bunch of other things, so
there's going to be plenty of
content for folks even if
you're not able to make
it to I/O to watch.
So stay tuned for that.
And this is Jeff Posnick, Kris
Schroder from Next Big Sound.
Thanks so much for watching our
show this week and we'll
talk to you soon.